moulage feuilletage et crème d'amande la
technique reste la même mais cette année
le pâtissier a ajouté un ingrédient à sa
recette la solidarité dans cette
boulangerie les galettes des rois pour
l'épiphanie seront vendus au profit du
secours populaire
j'ai plein de clients qui font des
actions caritatives à voisins le
bretonneux et magny les hameaux à
guyancourt à montigny est donc là
l'occasion m'a été donnée d'apporter ma
pierre à l'édifice avec des des fèves à
l'effigié du secours populaire pour
pouvoir faire des dons au secours
populaire pour pour aider les gens pour
chaque galette acheté un euro sera
reversé à l'association
c'est la première fois que l'artisan
boulanger participent à cette opération
son objectif est déjà bien établie il y
aura la remise d'un chèque officielle à
la fin de l'opération
ça change je me suis engagé à ce que je
ne leur verse pas moins de 6000 euros
c'est comme d'habitude sont des galettes
à la crème d'amande des galettes aux
pommes des galettes bordelaise
des galettes chocolat voilà un classique
5 feuilles différentes sont cachés dans
les galettes chacune d'elle représente
une action du secours populaire dans les
yvelines
trois boulangeries participe à la
galette solidaire jusqu'au 31 janvier
au total l'opération permettrait de
récolter près de 100000 euros